[Music]
Bernie Sanders has professed his
admiration for elements of Fidel
Castro's Cuba especially its massive
literacy program Sanders comments have
been roundly condemned but criticism has
focused on the human cost of Castro's
Cuba not the merits of the literacy
program itself turns out that the
program was hardly worth bragging about
even on its own terms first before
Castro seized power Cuba already boasted
one of the highest literacy rates in
Latin America during Castro's reign many
other nations increased their literacy
rates as much or more than Cuba second
countries self-report these data taking
Cuba's numbers at face value is to
accept a dictators propaganda third keep
in mind that the point of Castro's
program was not literacy but training
students to imbibe revolutionary dogma
the problem with Sanders celebration of
Cuba's literacy programs is not just
that the means were horrific but that
the ends weren't so great either do
Bernie Sanders views on Cuba affect your
opinion of him let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI